let's start with jordan peterson a
couple things related to jordan first
last night you may have seen this
the daily wire
ben shapiro's
news and entertainment and cultural
website
thing big thing it's a big thing at this
point uh they announced that they've
signed jordan peterson so uh that's
great news obviously for jordan and our
friends over at the daily wire
but the day was not perfect for jordan
because earlier in the day uh he was
suspended from twitter he remains
suspended on twitter right now and uh
let's throw the image up right here so
here's the tweet that got him suspended
now i just want to clarify for uh
chronology of this thing the tweet he
put up there is on june 22nd he was not
suspended until yesterday june 29th but
the tweet is remember when pride was a
sin
and ellen page just had her breasts
removed by a criminal
physician
so ellen page is the actress who
transitioned and i suppose is now known
as elliott page and she had her breasts
removed i don't know about the bottom
situation or anything like that but
throw the image up one more time what
twitter said about jordan's tweet and
again it was left up for a week
they said that it violated their rules
against hateful conduct you may not
promote violence against threaten or
harass other people on the basis of race
ethnicity national origin sexual
orientation gender gender identity
religious attention
sorry religious affiliation age
disability or serious disease now jordan
obviously did not promote violence
against anyone he is a clinical
psychologist and a world-renowned author
and speaker those were his thoughts
jordan has told me personally he is not
going to delete the tweet twitter will
not put him back unless he deletes the
tweet and he has said to me he will see
who blinks first uh of course myself
and several other uh people on twitter
are trying to defend jordan and that
then gets the progressive woke
genderless brigade to report you
repeatedly so my twitter account has
been under attack and i keep getting
these messages from twitter that i am
being reported to the german authorities
but fortunately at the moment i have
evaded
the german authorities there you go
twitter is required by german law to
provide notice users who are reported by
people in germany so germany's coming
after me we'll see what happens anyway
this is just a perfect example it's not
that the twitter thing is so important
and that we should all be lost in the
minutia of social media uh but these are
the cultural flames that end up becoming
these big uh fiery outbursts in our
political situation and it's like of
course twitter allows hate
of course twitter allows people to say
mean things and attack people and do all
of that stuff and in no way was jordan
instigating violence against anyone or
or against elliot or ellen or anyone
ellen whatever whatever
or anyone else